concern over the omicron variant of the
coronavirus which is leading to new
travel restrictions including for u.s
citizens our lead national correspondent
david begno is at jfk airport in new
york with more on that he's also got an
inside look on how scientists are
working to understand this new strain
david good morning
nate good morning the cdc is going to be
increasing testing surveillance at the
arrivals terminals for for the nation's
busiest airports we're talking atlanta
san francisco newark and john f kennedy
where we are this morning here in new
york city also within the next 24 hours
we expect an announcement that's going
to affect just about anybody traveling
to the u.s
late last night the cdc confirmed they
are working to modify the testing
requirements for travel into the united
states right now travelers have to be
tested within 72 hours of departing to
go to the united states but the white
house may soon announce that travelers
be tested one day before boarding
flights regardless of their vaccination
status or the state of covet in the
country that they're coming from
in the u.s the message is consistent get
vaccinated get your booster do it now
we have far more tools to fight the
variant today than we had at this time
last year one of those tools could be
the at-home pill for merck that would
fight the worst symptoms of the virus
and lower hospitalizations and deaths an
fda advisory panel on tuesday
recommended its use it is now up to the
fda to sign off
meanwhile there are labs around the u.s
testing right now to see where omicron
will pop up first
we're sequencing the cova genome of
thousands of positive covet samples we
went to the pandemic response lab which
is just outside new york city to meet
john laurent he is head of research and
development here the u.s is sequencing
80 000 positive pcr tests every week to
look for variants
that way they can determine how fast the
variants are spreading and how
infectious they are
about 2 000 of those sequences occur
right here our turnaround time here once
we get a sample in is is about three
days right now it is the delta variant
that makes up about 99 of the cases
worldwide
how long did it take for delta to become
the majority of all coveted positive
patients in new york city thinking back
on that i think it was probably six to
eight weeks
from the time we first sort of saw it
and then really saw it take off it took
off very quickly that's pretty fast yes
it was it was very fast so is it your
guess that once you detect omicron
within let's say a month and a half to
two months it could be the majority of
everything it could definitely be
think about that one more thing before
we go just to our north in canada a
negative test is no longer a substitute
as of now if you're 12 and older and
you're not vaccinated they won't let you
travel by plane or train
gail
all right david so many people working
so hard to keep us safe all we have to
do is do our part thank you very much
david begnell reporting